- Il y a beaucoup de choses
à faire sur vélo, fait que, oui,
on a l'impression de se sentir
comme une mécanicienne de vélo.
- Danyka Gaudreault acquiert,
depuis trois mois, de nouvelles
compétences chez Action Sport
Vélo, unVélo, unVélo, un organic
une double mission,
environnementale et sociale.
DANYKA GAUDREAULT, participante
- Il y a juste la chambre à air
à changer, puis enlever
la rouille, le laver.
- 25 000 vélos ont été recyclés
depuis 2005 grâce aux
trois points de services
de l'organisme d'Action Sport
Vélo à Windsor, Valcourt
et Acton Vale.
Près de 4000 bicyclettes ont pu
être remontées et revendues.
Les vélos irrécupérables
ont été démontés.
750 000 livres d'acier
ont ainsi été détournées
des sites d'enfouissement.
THOMAS FONTAINE, participant
- C'est impressionnant,
les quantités qu'on peut
récupérer. Et, bien, oui, l'idée
de leur donner une deuxième vie
aussi, c'est quand intéressa
pour les gens qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens
de s'en acheter un neuf.
- Ce qui étonne aussi
Yoann Denoual, formateur
au point de service de Windsor,
c'est de voir les changements
qui s'opèrent chees
adultes qui vivent ici
une initiation à l'emploi.
- Les progressions les plus
impressic'est
en termes de confiance en soi,
que ce soit au niveau mécanique
ou social, avec les clients,
c'est pas mal ça le plus
impressionnant, je dirais
et dont je suis le plus
content, honnête
- Danyka et Thomas Fontaine
trouvent ici de nouvelles
motivations. Leur stage
doit durines.
Quant au jeune Samuel Lacourse,
âgé de 13 ans, il participe
à un programme de 80 heures,
qui lui procure unprocure unproe
expérience de travail.
- On veut quelque chose,
pas se décourager, puis
continuer d'essayer de faire
des efforts pour l'obtenir.
- C'est un peu ce que
vous avez appris ici?
- Oui. J'irais avec ça.
- L'étape décisive pour savoir
vers je m'en vais, avec ce
stage-là, j'ai appris que
j'aimais beaucoup la mécanique,
la petite mécanique.
Puis j'aimerais peut-être ça
continuer en mécanique auto
- Depuis 2005, 320 jeunes
adultes ont réalis
chez Action Sport Vélo.
70 % d'entre eux ont trouvé
ensuite un autre emploi
ou sont retournés aux études.
Ici Guyette,ette,ette,ette,ett,